we want the guy who's actually taking
the steps to have control of when he
turns 20 steps which way he goes so
we're driving we are driving and
remember Peter the dry driver is going
to have big creature legs so he's
actually walking the legs as he's doing
this he has the control which is great
because he can stop if he kind of gets
tripped up or anything but man he won't
have to be hunched over like that so he
should be able to get big actually who's
great this rig will be with the
puppeteers close to 2,000 pounds what
you're seeing now is movement of both
the arms you're seeing now movement of
the head this is the final bottom so
this is the power is in place yep this
now has multifunction right I see your
wrist is moving we've got all the the
shoulder joints are up here the rotate
is on a really nice sturdy bearing this
is the head and then we're calling this
the base neck okay so it turns left and
right and I was concerned that it
wouldn't be able to look down enough but
with what the parallelogram does go all
the way down just imagine yeah this is
the first time that we've seen this
actually happened go to wired.com for
the entire giant creature series